[Musik]
hallo liebe
wir machen heute türkische teigtaschen
portland man die auf türkisch und heute
eine spezielle variante
wir machen nämlich sie mit porta sie mit
kind vielleicht unter diesen runden
zusammen kriegen und es gibt auch
porsche also dass sie mit potter das
sind dann einfach nur teigtaschen die
auch in diesem sesam gewälzt werden und
nach köstlich einfach noch köstlich ich
fange direkt an mit dem teig ich habe
jetzt hier mail in einer großen schüssel
werten die mengenangabe stehen immer
unten in der video beschreibung die
müsste auf klappen könnte direkt in
screenshot machen einkaufen gehen ich
habe ich eine kleine mulde drin gibt da
jetzt lauwarmes wasser dazu und dann
werde ich auch schon meine käfigen leyen
bröseln lassen
ihr könntet ihr auch alternativ
trockenhefe dies auch kein problem
[Musik]
jetzt noch zucker dazu einmal grob
verrühren so und nun zugedeckt fünf
minuten lang arbeiten lassen
arbeite gut genau so nach fünf minuten
einmal öffnen und salz und öl mit
dazugeben und dann könnte ich das in der
küchenmaschine erst mal so ein paar
minuten damit sich überhaupt zu dem teig
verbindet und dann machen wir sowieso
mit den händen weiter sie können auch
den ganzen tag mit den händen kneten
[Musik]
das besondere an diesem tag ist er
braucht kein ei und das ist schon sehr
sehr geschmeidig also ich hab jetzt
wirklich nur zwei minuten oder so
geknetet deshalb ist das ganze rezept
auch vegan möglich falls veganer unter
uns sind dann müsste einfach nur in der
füllung veganen käse nehmen so und jetzt
gebe ich dann einmal in die schüssel
zurück gesprüht sie noch ein bisschen
mit back krems prey das mache ich immer
gerne wenn ich nicht möchte dass noch
mehr mail an den teil kommt damit der im
schön geschmeidig bleibt bisschen nach
oben drüber dass die haut ein bisschen
benetzt ist einmal den deckel drauf und
jetzt an einem warmen ort 45 minuten
lang gehen lassen
[Musik]
für die leckere füllung verrühren wir
jetzt ganz einfach schafskäse mit gouda
käse und petersilie und fertig ist
unsere köstliche füllung der liebe ich
total
wir können auch die kartoffel variante
nehmen die us-variante verlinkt euch mal
mein stamm ab orten porträts sind in die
infobox ihr könnt ihr euch das auch
gerne mal ansehen ist ein sehr altes
video und jetzt nehme ich mir den teig
keine panik hat eine schüssel wechsel
weil ich den tag x vorbereitet habt gibt
ihn mir auf die arbeitsfläche und dann
unter teile ich mit meiner teig karte
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich zwölf kugeln geformt und
ihr müsst sie nicht noch mal geben
lassen wir liegen direkt los mit der
füllung
ich habe jetzt hier eine teil kugel und
ich brauche noch nicht mal ein nudelholz
ich habe jetzt einfach die hände und
breite das oval aus da kommt jetzt ein
esslöffel von der käse füllung rein und
dann wird das einfach verschlossen
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt ein sehr spannender teil
das ist auch unerlässlich wenn ihr sie
mit porzer machen möchtet wir brauchen
trauen sie rum und ich werde oft gefragt
ob man trauben sirup des ersetzen kann
meiner meinung nach nicht ich habe bei
einer zuschauerin gelesen hatte sirup
und der bei uns im shop bestellen hat
gelabert
es gibt kein traumjob nämlich der sirup
und sie meinte es hat ganz gut geklappt
aber alle angaben ohne gewähr es ist
jetzt nur eben ihre erfahrungsberichte
und es gebe ich jetzt zum traum truppen
und bisschen wasser verrührt das und in
die andere schade gebe ich sesam der
kann gerüstet sein oder umgerüstet dass
es egal es kommt der eben im backofen
und anschließen wird immer ein porsche
in das trauma sirup gemisch gewählt dann
in sesam und dann direkt aufs backblech
[Musik]
so und dann schneide ich noch die
oberfläche an circa drei mal einfach der
optik wegen und jetzt kann das ganze
auch schon in den backofen wandern
der ist vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober und
unterhitze und dann packen wir die
supporters im unteren drittel
für circa 25 minuten ist kann auch eine
minute weniger dauern
schaut dass sie nicht zu dunkel werden
sonst im goldbraun sind dann sind es
auch richtig schön fluffig zu diesem
rezept kann ich nur sagen werde ich
sicher nicht ausprobiert ist selbst
schuld das klingt hart aber es ist
wirklich so ihr müsst es unbedingt
ausprobieren und mir euer feedback hier
unten in die kommentare schreiben
und dann wünsche ich euch jetzt einfach
nur noch viel spaß beim nachbacken viel
spaß beim genießen am besten lauwarm mit
tee kaffee oder einfach zum frühstück
passt einfach immer und macht mich nicht
verantwortlich wenn ihr richtig werde
das ist nämlich ganz normal bei diesem
rezept ansonsten noch wunderschönen tag
und bis zum nächsten mal auf die gis
kitchen schieben das vergisst das update
[Musik]